hey everyone hey and welcome back to yet
another episode of watching the Watchmen
this is a start of a new series on the
channel where we're not going through
Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons as such
we're going through Geoff Johns and
what's his name Gary Frank had to
quickly let that overshadow Gary Frankie
sir he's a fellow Brit yeah we go from
Doomsday Clock which you may be aware of
it's essentially Watchmen - it seems at
least from the first issue it's quite
exciting and it there's quite a little
bit of serendipity really in the fact
that we start doing shawm Watchmen and
pretty soon after the sequel to Watchmen
is coming out in stores so yet dooms
they're all jumping on the bandwagon
I'm sick of them we thought what did
unique doing a watchman podcast about 50
of them have popped up in the last week
that's true that's true
there is always better names I think
Damon Lindelof he's like on one as well
so it's kind of like you know Connor
maybe it might we can get more than
those well maybe we might have Alan more
on this later to review Doomsday Clock
yeah keep an eye out for that listeners
so um so Doomsday Clock which you're
gonna get into as we say I'm sure you're
aware if you listen to watch me if you
know about Watchmen is the sequel as I
say it's a twelve issue run you know
it's officially in stores it's not kind
of a trade paperback or hardback
whatever me and deaf for having to pick
up the issues month by month and we've
got issue one in front of us now we've
read it I'm sure you've probably read it
I'm gonna just go through it and offer
our our thoughts on this series I should
say just for we get involved into that
you know please subscribe to the show
please comment I want to say thank you
to everyone that's listening the
listenership has been picking up
stronger and stronger each week you know
we're getting a consistent download base
now which is awesome if you want to get
in touch with the show watching The
Watchmen part at gmail.com what are your
thoughts on Doomsday Clock or any of the
issues that we've read in the past I've
gotten loads of great emails we're gonna
be reading out on the next episode which
I believe is the abyss cases also the
Rorschach issue is u6 so send you
messages in will definitely read them
out as well share the episodes you know
recommend to fellow Watchmen fans fellow
graphic novel fans but um yeah we're
gonna get into this deaf how's it going
man
yeah really good and so I'm a bit
annoyed at Warner Brothers in DC at the
moment and because I did it it took us
absolutely ages to edit this rank in the
Batman films from 1966 to Justice League
age as it was I download all the clips
edit them you know what it was the first
ever YouTube video I did with video and
instead of just static images
anyway I upload it unlisted Warner
Brothers put a bloody copyright strike
on my channel so though what I've been
doing since then I've been a massive DC
fan for the past 15 years or bought
loads of their graphic novels I've
started by in bloody Marvel ones instead
yesterday I got meself the Marvel
blu-ray phase-one collection and bought
Civil War for 67 pence on Amazon I
bought old man Logan above daredevil I'm
going on a Marvel binge by you know what
I'm saying Tom I guess hook DC [ __ ]
Warner Brothers I'm not giving them any
more money
what you mean they've just released a
single issue of Watchmen for 5 pounds to
take me money take me this patreon as
well yeah yeah yeah oh yeah that would
be deaths patreon he's hopefully can get
on board the servers are overloaded
because people are donating there but
maybe so so yeah I mean I don't this is
as we've all bloody giant DC Marvel
comic things it's not just one story
there's loads of issues beforehand you
know give context and explain things so
I haven't actually read sort of the
precursors to Doomsday Clock such as the
button give us a quick sort of you know
preamble quick play-by-play well luckily
Tom you don't need you a read it at all
because it doesn't really tie into this
basically what happens in the button is
Batman and flash they get attacked by
the reverse-flash who travels through
time comes back like seconds later
he's been attacked by dr. Manhattan he
says he's seen God and this all happened
because he touched the button the famous
button from Watchmen you know with the
blood could the comedian's button for
you well first off it's not a button
it's a badge but skip all that to budge
um yeah so they kind of go searching for
exactly what happened they travel
through time Batman meets his dad in the
flashpoint universe who was Batman
basically all that yeah it doesn't
really massively influenced her that
much there was also DC rebirth as well
which yeah just kind of hinted that the
Watchmen existed within the DC Universe
but it wasn't you know you dad don't
really think then necessities you want
to dive straight in it boom snake walk
and you know Doomsday Clock as a whole
as an issue every time we're discussing
Watchmen we're always looking at the
front cover first what he can tell us I
mean it's pretty clear it's a watchman
comic isn't it it's got do you have a
clogged up the spine in the yellow and
black it's got the clock the artwork you
can see he's the [ __ ] Ozymandias with
a you know of a cross over his face as
it's got an interesting cover of
anything else yeah and it says January
2018 at the bottom which I never get
away the labor do all the time with
comics whether put like two months ahead
on it yeah so if someone can explain why
that is I know magazines often do one
month ahead but this this is like Daniel
Reed says stops on Manhattan and he's
messing with the timeline he's crazy
that lad
he's blowed out the deed everday so here
we have you know I guess if you've
watched Watchmen the covers kind of you
can sort of anticipate what's happening
here the aftermath of what's called the
great lie in the comic books the sauce
weird attack I mean we're seeing the hoi
polloi
we're seeing you know basically
Rorschach sign yet again there's a
Molotov and a lit bottle in the top
right it's not exactly more Gibbons but
I can deal with it yeah what's annoying
is it now ruins the ending of Watchmen
instantly so [ __ ] all those 12 issues
of Watchmen for you know 30 a legacy all
the murder in New York and the attacks
and Russia and stuff like that all the
characters gone through in a turmoil and
there were all the waste of time and
because yet the lads have found out it
was all alive yeah it was yeah it's
confusing that they kept going with the
story but I guess we've just got to keep
going with it as well and I don't know
about you but just in a general sense I
was expecting it to be at least you know
the first issue the DC Universe meets
watch yeah but effectively it's Watchmen
- yeah it literally is
they throw Superman in at the end and
but yeah it's very harmful and doesn't
feel like it ties into the really at all
I mean they mentioned dr. Manhattan's
God and then they tie that in the
Superman being God but yeah this
literally didn't need that to be honest
no no it didn't and it's I mean we begin
you know it's gonna be like [ __ ]
force awakens isn't it it's gonna be
like it's oh it's kind of new hope it's
like everything's kind of so we open
with pulling out from something for us
words where it was a button now it's the
end is near sign it's just a bit kind of
this homage and then there's just
pandering yeah and one of my biggest
problems with this issue is they
literally like write it exactly as Alan
Moore would have wrote it but Alan were
never would have wrote something exactly
like someone else so it's kind of
paradoxical and it's it's very much it's
like copying someone's homework and put
it as you know you try and change bits
and bobs there but it it shouldn't be
credited to you it should be credited to
the other person their brilliance yeah
yeah so I mean obviously they want to
keep the aesthetic of Watchmen it's all
kind of will be interesting to see
because I know before Watchmen is really
like different and worse
work and as we get on to that little
kind of be interesting to see which we
prefer but for now I'm just kind of like
I've seen it done bare by the original
writer yeah yeah that's kinda the trap
that a lot of creatives are falling into
at the moment not only in this like in
Hollywood where they're pretty much just
remaking someone's work instead of
making their own and it's always gonna
have that kind of shadow over the top of
it it is someone like Moore as well
who's got such an individual genius I
mean every episode we praise just his
writing not not the story just literally
how good Wright's characters how good he
describes things and you know when I was
first writing this issue and you know
spoilers I thought it was Rorschach
obviously it's not Rorschach I can kind
of forgive some of the hammy nurse
because it's not Rorschach so I guess
that's what they're going for but even
then it's just a bit like afraid a bit
of geoff johns before and like he's more
of a story guy to me i think he's
actually kind of pen writing he's a bit
flat see I really like him in general
like absolutely love is Batman earth one
series its Justice League run I thought
was phenomenal its flashier even as
flash stuff was really really good and
he revitalized the lot of the characters
what a lot of people criticized him for
and some people praised him for is that
sort of takes things back to the status
quo like a lot of his basically brought
Barry Allen back from the dead left
after 20 years and a lot of people
praised him for how he was able to
recapture the original spirit and no
feeling of those flash books that Barry
Allen was a major part of and a lot of
his work it sort of is derivative and do
you really like it but I can see why
people would have runs with it however
this book I'm kind of like yeah you took
it a bit too far and it sort of feels
like it's not your work like Geoff Johns
is a really good writer
and he could have done so much more yeah
yeah this is the
impossible job yeah just don't do it
don't do an IGN and stuff are giving it
like nine out attends and I'm just
thinking like you know have you recently
read the original because I think the
fact that we have might shine this in a
bad light if you'd read the original
like two or three years ago you you
might pick this up and go who and you
know it's something new it's something
fresh we're I think we're like you're
ruining my childhood you're ruining it
George Lucas you ruined it
the yeah I I don't know I think if I
still read this without really much but
I'd be a bit it's just a bit on the nose
like the certain things I like visually
I like them going towards the the Veidt
Plaza and the broken bottle kind of
mirroring the V like yeah again it's a
bit kind of I don't like make America
safe again with that sign there is no
real purpose for other than a wink wink
and we've seen so many make XX again
parodies already it was just a bit like
you know this is a bit of a dead
reference and so much honestly I really
don't think there would be an uprising
like this I think people were too
apathetic and stuck you know in there
well let someone else sort this out
mindset and there was a great bit in in
the Dark Knight three the master race
where the Kryptonians invade earth and
no one really cares because they're all
just walking around looking at the
phones and the Kryptonians are like
hovering above them like why won't they
pay attention to us so they just go and
destroy like all the mobile satellites
in the world and then suddenly people
like start looking up from the phones
and like oh my god you have to take down
this threat I mean people just saw
apathetic I don't want to get into
conspiracy theories but bloody Bush did
9/11 there's a lot of people who do and
there hasn't been any kind of uprising
against it so I really don't see why
just because Rorschach's Journal was
found with saying Adrian by
destroyed several capital cities that
people would suddenly leap to their feet
and then do something about it on the
front of the main paper you know and
it's kind of being pushed by the media
but yeah I I get what you're saying and
again there's so many moments in this is
you're like oh this location like when
they enter obviously we see the Egyptian
head where he killed the assassin but
it's just juxtapositions the name of the
game in Watchmen and them saying we
shattered the American Dream and a brick
shattering glass it's just a bit broad
yeah it's not one the nose is never um I
think we are lucky that we did recently
reread issue 5 because I probably
wouldn't have remembered that
I'm Sphinx head pool that the assassin
got murdered in there are some nice
callbacks like the great line newspapers
surrounded by Ozymandias dolls on the
desk which is it's the same angle that
appeared in the original comic but yeah
it just kind of feels by this there's
nothing that really comes from this
surprising I was really hoping because a
couple of months ago Geoff Johns did
like a preview of the first couple of
pages and I was hoping that the people
who were finally gonna like get
Ozymandias and like tear and limb from
limb well that there's nothing that
really comes from this other than the
people don't like them you might be a
little bit of when the the sort of anti
supers break into Hollis Mason's garage
and so p.m. and it's kind of got that
sort of mob mentality and and yeah and
the world is sort of spell out comics
have to do this so I'm not really
blaming geoff johns to sort of spell out
the geopolitical landscape the best way
to do it is through news reports so you
know the world's pretty much the same
yeah which to me you do one of the other
i mean it proudly puts on the front that
this is a 12 issue rug now when stuffs
getting at the same point is getting put
across twice it's just kind of like you
just waste in time of it yeah there's a
lot of time wasting filler yeah
- there's a lot there's some nice
moments cuz they have to run noisy so I
like how hundreds have broken through
the wall and flooded into Mexico
thousand more are predicted to follow
which is nice that we see sort of the
president's golf bag is what it's all
very sort of like wink wink but it's you
know yeah it's fine and then we get you
know updates on how our watchmen friends
are doing document hands still missing
you know can be murdered you know the
cancer fairies mentioned a night owl is
gone Silk Spectre has vanished
Ozzy remains at large um I don't really
maybe I'm just not getting this I don't
really understand this sequence where
the guys are breaking into this snow
palace and then witnessing like a ultra
scan as human dies has got brain cancer
oh yeah that's that's been to show that
which again is another point it's a bit
oh yeah they say once and then they say
it later in the issue and it could have
done it either way to be honest so yeah
I took my Wyatts well you know let the
lab the lads obviously got his job for
the reason that he's good so let the lad
tell his story my mom stops lagging a
moth bees I guess it's just I don't know
it's just the huge reaction this is gone
and it's like I don't want to be I don't
to be a snob but I just like I think the
whole thing's okay you know I read quite
a lot of comics now and I'm often like
bloody hell I'm really like pumped after
reading something and this I'm just a
bit like yeah yeah well I suppose that
Rorschach's work inevitably led on a
destructive and chaotic path and which
sort of symbolizes rorschach himself so
you know Rorschach through his life was
he just did everything his own way no
compromises um so obviously a legacy
left behind by him is sort of gonna
shadow that and so I suppose this is
sort of what happens when you follow
madmen blindly the the orders gone and
chaos is now king you could argue
being a successful hero or superhero is
creating a legacy look at night out for
example with Dan following Hollis and
it's kind of a compliment in a twisted
way to Rorschach's means that someone
else takes up his mantle after he dies
yeah and just the people in general just
going mental in smashing stuff up yeah
so the world is pretty much draw shock
now yeah yeah and we meet Rorschach and
I allowed to call him raw black is that
is that um PC that's a bit racist to be
ok let's not let's not continue that but
um so we're in the prison as we always
are with Watchmen to a certain extent
and I'm truly racist um apologize and
I've gotta say you know the shot when we
get into the you know the keys being
punched and then Rorschach Rorschach's
l-tron Leroy check bending down with the
keys and we have the like I don't know
Matt you my heart swelled when I saw
that it was pretty [ __ ] cool to see
Rorschach back in the comics yeah it was
in that moment instantly like taken away
later when you find out that it's not
actually raw sure I always barkis back
the lad is black yeah
just disappointment not because I'm a
racist like you so yeah you know we have
Rorschach wandering through we have his
journal again which again is sort of
signs to the fact that maybe it's 9 this
there's an annoying thing for me and I
don't know if I'm being really petty
here but basically he says he talks
about getting revenge on someone's
boyfriend in quite a brutal rocky way
broke hands put fork through tongue
forgot to tell him why and there's a
latest sequence when him and marionette
and the mime are going and the
marionette says the same thing says like
I'll stick a tongue through your fork
into a table it's just like Jeff could
you not not replicate that it's not ok
or yeah well to me I'm gonna be proper
matter right now
but a new person taking up the mantle of
Rossa
copying the exact same way he talks all
those mannerisms its saw
similar to the way that Geoff Johns has
taken up the mantle of Malinois and
copied all of his mannerisms all the way
talks and just regurgitated everything
that he's done so well done Jeff gone
you've managed to analyze yourself and
media in general where we're just people
are just taking the same old ideas
regurgitating them and making them a bit
[ __ ] I like that I like that I think
I think yet Jeff has probably done the
huge beards
he's now worshipping a snake sex guard
living in Northampton yes he's gone full
Alan Moore which is yeah you know not a
bad place to be again my problem with a
lot of this issue is a very long section
which essentially boils down to new
Rorschach getting people out of prison
and taking them somewhere in you know in
Moore's universe you sort of taken a few
panels here it takes most of the bloody
book yeah and what's annoying is the
book introduces three new characters and
all of them are pretty crap yeah also
have Russia invading Poland as well
remember if in the original Watchmen
book if the Second World War happened
yeah well because he acknowledged
Vietnam definitely did obviously but the
Second World War I can't remember if
that happened or not I don't know if
it's even mentioned to be honest with
you but maybe didn't that thing yeah
which obviously if it didn't happen then
Russia doing this is gonna be a huge
thing so it is it's quite a big thing
Rorschach again he they they have
captured exactly how Rorschach was like
he speaks in definitive statements it's
all black and white not black like that
you've ruffled Lazarus yeah and it's
just all very you know hear them behind
the doors hear them all screaming to get
out silence it's all very definitive and
so they have managed to recapture that
but
don't know just it was disappointing
when it I seen it wasn't actually the
real Rorschach why would people come
back in comics all the time like there's
only two people who ever stayed dead
well you know what I was gonna say Uncle
Ben and the Wayans but obviously Thomas
Waynes come back now it's [ __ ] Batman
slow oh yeah
no one ever stays dead in comics so it
would have been nice to kind of see them
see them bringing back in a I don't know
a different way yeah someone else copy
it unless Jeff Jones was purposely like
look yeah I'm stealing all this stuff
and making it look like a Malinois but
I'm not Jeff Jones listens to this
podcast so he's probably gonna say that
in it yeah it's a shame maybe like when
he was vaporized in the snow palace it
kind of allowed him to I don't know they
they could have done something no one
would have been too annoyed but it's not
it's someone else yeah taking everything
it's gonna be anyone from the main story
involved in what oh I mean this theories
that it's the therapist or the black
freighter kid yeah I was gonna say the
black freighter kid what another theory
that I've seen that might be true is
it's the question and so yes which is
obviously a DC Universe character um so
if people don't know basically when DC
bought the right they're bought Charlton
comics they got the rights to the like
characters like we'd be old captain Adam
the question who wanted to use for
Watchmen but DC wouldn't let him do it
um so it would be good if it was like a
cool little twist that the character
that Rorschach was based on actually was
the character from the DC Universe and
within the DC Universe basically when
the new 52 happened pandora that the
Phantom Stranger and the question were
all sort of this Trinity of evil
characters that were cursed
to walk the earth forever and sort of
going through things like the Phantom
Stranger wouldn't be able to know anyone
and pandora was sort of cursed and the
question was basically someone who as
soon as they did if they didn't know the
answer to something it like burned
inside of them and had to investigate
gay ed and get to the bottom of it and
so would be good if that kind of turned
out a beer or shag and it would easily
meld the two universes together and
because the question is sort of a
mystical figure and you know he could
probably travel through dimensions so
that would be like a cool little thing I
was thinking the black freighter got
Kidd as well but I'm pretty sure he gets
killed yes yes yeah you see them selves
embracing though new as the atomic bomb
you know it wouldn't make yeah Howard
yes right he how would he survive yeah
and I forgot to mention that him
dr. Manhattan actually kills Pandora at
the start of rebirth oh so one year one
of the people that was very closely
linked with the question and dr. Mahan's
murdered so yeah my kind of tie into
that book will see it could just be a
bloody anyone could be honest it could
be and you know these can be your maid
Tom because I know you've got loads of
luck and the characters that were
meeting of your Mariner and mine are
Charlton Comics characters in themselves
okay yeah yeah punch and Julie they
first appeared in Captain Atom 85 in
1967 which was drawn by Steve Ditko
they've actually appeared in Batman as
well and on a secret Suicide Squad oh
yeah oh yeah yes oh so they've been
around in in in various form so again
John's is playing with that Charlton as
Fetty yeah which I really like appeared
recently in Batman like one of the
latest graphic novels they were in oh I
didn't realize that was punching in 2d I
thought it was just yeah Julie it's a
very very soul thing there and another
sort of thing that I like here because
obviously would die hard watching a fan
so whenever anyone makes reference that
only we would get it is nice and I like
when she's playing with Rorschach's
identity and saying you said you dropped
me you said you
romi down an elevator shaft the next
time we met and he said it wasn't me not
the same guy different obviously
referring to were old rejected to
captain carnage which is gear instead
think by you know dreiberg and and Silk
Spectre on the rooftop at the end of the
first issue but yeah it's just nice it's
just it's well building yeah and you
know it's up until that moment way takes
his hand off I was I was all in on this
book even if I did have you know some
problems with the start
um but yeah it's yeah I don't know what
so she's still trusting of this
Rorschach character even though she
knows that the original hated her I
don't know I only know how this is gonna
pay off to be honest it's ya know it's a
bit of shame that it's it's of a rescue
mission for a child it's just a bit it's
a bit small really for something like
the earth bit cliche as well yeah we've
got we're gonna save your kid you know I
mean after 30 years when they're talking
about like getting the DC Universe and
the Watchmen universe and putting them
together I thought like it would open on
I don't know Superman landing in the
Watchmen universe and seeing the world
getting torn apart yes well it's just
yeah I mean we're in our first issue you
know we we can't be too critical but
again just you know an atomic on the
next two panels are literally him
showing the photo then fighting and
arguing back and forth it's not that
interesting what you know and eventually
we get the mine next who we meet a lot
of people as well have compared punching
Julie to Harley Quinn and Joker which I
guess they are kind of these you know
Marilyn murderous love couples yeah it's
a nice archetype um so maybe they're
gonna kind of team up down the line or
something but at the moment you're
taking up a massive chunk of the first
issue with these characters but I don't
know why I should care they're not
interested in or they know and even in
the batman book that i mean that i
literally read that book last week um my
website definition of coda UK yeah
and the fact that I didn't even draw
those comparisons shows how
uninteresting they were in that book
like they were such side characters in
that that they just leave no impression
so I don't know why they've been brought
in to this so massively I mean there
might be like you know Star Trek red
shirts it's called where they just send
people on missions to get killed
hmm do you know that's a in tight mhmm
wearily yes are basically asked when
Star Trek when they're like Captain Kirk
and I lads used to go down to a planet
it always takes some lads down with them
with know the ones in the red shirts
just so that people could get killed off
so it looked like there was stakes but
these characters no one give a [ __ ]
about them there were just that I get
murdered and so maybe it's gonna be like
one of them you never know but I doubt
it
yeah and the mom in prison you know
waiting for them to come to get him he's
similar to when Walter Kovacs was
sitting in prison waiting for all the
prisoners who want to cut him off which
yeah would you think a lot absolute
wrong I can prison some of the best
stuff in Watchmen but yeah yeah he gets
picked up he gets man Hannah reason to
fight back and then eventually Rorschach
gets involved gets rescued pretty brutal
scenes here the guy's teeth being
smashed on the bar and then you you
don't quite see the mime fight you kind
of see that these sort of lorry move at
the end it's very intricate and then
he's what what do you make of his face
that crazed face with blood on the mouth
yeah that's what do you see the joke of
comparison there obviously by the blood
sort of looks like a red lipstick smile
um yeah maybe that's what they do in mmm
I don't really care I mean you've
already got the Joker
so yeah I'll stick I'll stick with the
character he's been run for 75 years and
is often cited as one of the best
villains in any media I'd stick with him
Jones Thanks
what thanks all the same no yeah you
haven't got time for the guy who gets
his gimmicky you know weapons from an
empty Locker no not not anymore Tom I'm
off to Marvel now I'm off Marvell
off to Marvel sod these lads only put a
copyright strike on me Channel I'm
really not I'm really not name with him
yet in the utility bar the locker I
think it's badly drawn as well for one
ie it's just not really there's no real
weight to his actions and you know it's
kind of explaining him as a force like
okay so he's clearly very deadly but he
has his own rules we got to obey them
but it's just a little bit twee yeah
just kill that Rorschach just kill them
the first chance you get just just get
rid of the lad please Josh I think it
doesn't stop you know they go out to the
car they have an argument about the
color of the car I'd quite like well you
can't see through this mask you know are
can see fruit pies yes or thing you know
obviously we discussed this before the
way the Rorschach views the world but
these free as a trio they're just not
very interesting the way they play off
each other yeah one of the em in rebirth
basically the entry they had reduced the
idea that there were three Joker's mmm
so Batman disco band basically sits on
the Mobius chair which gives the person
sat in it all of the information in the
universe and he asks who's the Joker and
it answers back that there's three so
maybe this is one of the Joker's that
then kind of bring it into it he might
end up being the first Joker or he could
be the second or something like that and
we'll just have to see how it pays off
but for the moment I'm just like I don't
really care
there's evacuations happening in New
York yeah
mandatory ones as well it's not quite
clear what's happening but obviously the
world is in some serious peril we are
yeah you know we're back again in
similar surroundings I do quite like how
all of the cars driving away from the
city are sort of those futuristic yeah
and round ones where is the the one
Rorschach's driving is sort of a you
know - OH
old yeah yeah be HUP card sort of shown
that this guy's stuck in the past almost
hmm and while everyone who's in the
future sort of moving away from this
metropolis and was he's sort of heading
back there yeah yeah yeah and we see the
Ganga diner as well we see him sort of
crawling beneath the service you know
it's all very super - Quinn I mean when
the mind points an imaginary gun at
Rorschach EU with that no yeah it's a
bit I don't know II just I would have
just turned around and broke his fingers
would have done yeah like he threw a guy
down an elevator shaft shouted punish me
hmm so you would not be sticked putting
up with any of this lot [ __ ] no but I
mean here they all are going back
through essentially back to the Batcave
of this universe into Dan drybeck's but
again it's just so slow like there's
literally free pages of them going
underground and reaching it it's kind of
crazy yeah I think you like how there's
two of the the suet onna sort of look
like Archie's yeah eyes like the night
owls ship yeah we see Archie as well
briefly and yeah you know you see the
night I'll sue and there's there's lots
of cool stuff and then from the shadows
death it's awesome and yes yeah when he
comes out like a James Bond villain
yeah I'm petting a cat um yeah he's got
his pet links back he's in full costume
which I don't mean oh I'd be honest no
cuz but is this symbolized and he's like
back in that man I love because in the
majority of Watchmen he was wearing a
suit hmm um yeah yeah and for some
reason he needs the help of these people
to find dr. Manhattan and Rorschach's
involved and it's all a bit and in your
first issues you have to get all your
characters together to push for I
understand that like you know it's got
to be a little bit messy but it just it
doesn't really Co here for me
naturally no it just seems like hey
remember this okay now remember this bit
hey remember this it's just sort of you
remember John what's the actual clock
this book please tell me what the pliers
yeah yeah there's lots of kind of cute
interactions between them but it's not
actually Rorschach so it's like well
this isn't that much fanservice I mean
he has like a little Bubastis with him
as well and he you know yeah he's
reminiscing because we learn in the
newspaper that the end of issue that I
think it's like the seven years
following was actually really good for
the world and then obviously people
found out and it's point of his desk
more which inevitably was gonna happen
yeah him saying laughing until it hurts
it's quite good artwork okay so you can
see the sort of frustration in his
project yeah I don't know it's just kind
of like like the third watchman the
original book opens on comedian get
murdered and you just kinda like woke
someone actually murdered a superhero
where is this it's like yeah just
getting characters together he has
cancer with apparently some sort of
projecting narrative for now it's like
yeah which I suppose is ironic because
he obviously gave so many people cancer
and blamed dr. Manhattan for forgiving
people cancer but yeah I just don't I
don't know how what like if they were
like super intelligent telekinesis
people okay maybe they can find dr.
Manhattan I just don't know how these
streetfighters Marinette am i but gonna
help the project I don't I don't get it
yeah I don't either
which is why I kind of think they're red
shirts yeah or there one of them is
gonna become the Joker and maybe the
other one will become Poliquin or their
kids is important yeah maybe but yeah
yeah I mean that that is essentially how
the story ends you get a quick sort of
glimpse back into the final issue which
is brilliant I love I mean obviously
gonna cover this in the show but when
the final doctor man and Ozzy wonders
interaction where where Z is left with
no satisfaction at all and sort of
pondering what you know what he's done
that is our mission we need to find John
and then we cut to
good old Clark in this final sequence
which again it's just like I can't stand
people waking up from dreams and then
predicting the future of the story it's
so lazy yeah it's a that thing where
they show like like a climatic climactic
thing at the start of something and then
go three weeks earlier it's just kind of
like you lazy start the story where it
should be like give me a good
introduction and I'll care about it you
know don't start that story had the
interesting part and then take me to a
more boring one and I don't know I kind
of took from it that where dr. Manhattan
saying I'm leaving this galaxy for one
less complicated that he either created
the DC Universe or he might have created
Krypton and then from there sent
Superman back to earth but I don't
really know how the two universe is in
its wine No yeah just kind of here's one
universe by if you were reading this and
you weren't aware that of the multiverse
in the DC universe you would just think
that they all exist on the same planet
yeah and and you would be like worldwide
Superman not getting involved in
stopping Ozymandias there's no clear-cut
narrative that this is a different
universe and I do are really one of my
biggest problems with as much as I love
the DC movies they require a lot of
prior knowledge like Justice League you
you pretty much have to know all of the
backstories already for the heroes
because they give very little indication
of exactly what happened and yeah it's
to me it's bad writing
you're not only opening on a dream
you're also like not explaining to new
readers that this is a different
universe yeah yeah I completely agree
and one of the things that johns
continues I like is the books in
Watchmen there's lots of references to
very arcane stuff we see on Superman's
shelf saris bedside Walden 2 by BF
Skinner
I'm literally reading off Wikipedia I've
not heard of it before obviously I've
heard of Walden
Walden's quite a famous old American Tex
from the 1850s about sort of
self-reliance and spiritualism in nature
and stuff like that very influential
Walden too is a utopian novel first
published in 1948 in its time it could
have been considered science fiction
since science based methods for altering
people's behavior did not exist yet it's
controversial because its character
speak of a rejection of free will
including rejection of the proposition
that human behavior is controlled by a
noncorporeal entity such as a spirit or
a soul I mean take that where you will
in terms of watchmen but it's quite
fitting and its themes yeah pretty much
symbolizes dr. Manhattan does now
yeah yeah essentially I think this is
how if you were to just sell Doomsday
Clock on a sentence it would be dr.
Manhattan meet Superman yeah he doesn't
know yet maybe he will yeah um he dreams
of the creek he may see in this Clark
looks back to you know his high school
days and and you know when he was off by
Lana and like he can't be hurt but he's
sad at the prom and you know all this
year like I think I don't know if I said
you before but I've been rereading
all-star Superman which yeah might be
one of my favorite sort of series ever I
think it's unbelievable I think the
imagination and I think especially
issue-free
where Lois Lois gets given Superman suit
for the day and gets yeah I just I just
think it's so much brilliant yeah but
but this sort of stuff it's just I don't
know sometimes Superman if it's done
badly can be quite just melodramatic and
this kind of plays that tone for me yeah
it's just kind of and just the way that
I like ends on I've never had a
nightmare before it's like come on right
you would have had a nightmare because
nightmares are just things you worry
about like he even you know I mean I've
had nightmares of being in school and
I've looked down and I've got no pants
on you know I mean like no in school
when I was like 28 you know what I mean
like when I was 15 you know I wasn't
dreaming I was in school can I just
clear it up I don't dream I'm naked at
school anyway you have stupid nightmares
like that um so course he would
no marriage no nightmares just your
imagination go to dark places and I mean
if the if a lot of Superman's never had
a name as he not seen the Justice League
rotten tomorrow score you having that
he's never had a name at has he not seen
the CGI mustache that get rid of just
has he not seen the box-office takings
for just he's just I I sort of know why
he's saying that he's kind of this
perfume in' he's put excited he has just
gone through so many adventures witness
so much carnage like you know there's
nothing wrong with having nightmares and
it's just kind of I don't know it's the
obvious ominous he's signifying some
sort of great shifting toe breach just
again a bit sort of like it doesn't play
into the character for me yeah but I
really don't like when boobs end on this
sort of Samba oh well you thought it was
this but it's actually this tone like it
again it to me it's like a lazy way of
ending something it's like and it's very
easy to do in comics like literally you
could like you could get the Incredible
Hulk he's having a dream and then he
wakes up in baby brunt or whatever she
was called I don't know I named you she
goes oh hey Bruce whoa why are you
sweating he's like I am no angry she's
like are you hungry and he's like no
that's the thing Betty I'm not angry you
know it's just kind of it's yeah it's
just kinda mm-hm
yeah it's not the best ending and you
know again we get a quote this from
Horace Smith's translation of Percy
Shelley's Ozymandias or I should say
Horace material he meets some fragment
huge and stops the guess what path
Wilbur unrecorded race once dwelt in
that annihilated place so again it's not
got more sort of comedic often Roy like
you think song notes it's literally an
epic poem about like an literally called
Ozymandias it's like
yeah it's it just tiny well like in the
fact that John's has Google as
fingertips as well and I kind of get the
feeling just like searched well as human
diets and quota so where is more like
hand selected his quotes from my books
yeah whereas this kind of just is like
oh yeah went on there I went on
Wikipedia the other day in pressed
random Oracle control-f oh where ever
came up I mean at the end as well
dedicated to Len Wein or ween who sadly
passed away
September 10th this year 2017 and he was
the editor of Watchmen
so he's huge incredible done tons of
tons of stuff as well just took another
guy's Wikipedia page no right that's the
best bit in the book yeah when they say
dedicated to him and then we get I mean
I was curious actually before open this
issue are we gonna get what Watchmen
always had the sort of addendum the
literature and we do get it to a certain
extent yeah we get the front page the
New York Gazette which is teased which
sort of explains where we are in the
story the you know Ozzie for many years
lived as an ambassador a president
Redford so you got out the celebrity
president having you yeah and just yeah
and then some other stuff as well
there's mentions of Byron Lewis passing
away who was Mothman I believe we see
Schrodinger's clock and watch her pet
it's all very cute references let's talk
about the guy who gets the journal at
the end of Watchmen was brutally beaten
in a break-in gone wrong which is how
they described the murder of the
comedian so maybe Ozzie sort of did
something there who knows or someone
else's there there are tools for combat
there is certain the adverts for a
combination prior at all I don't quite
know where that's been advertised
there's morning Jose where the logo
looks like cup head and have you seen
that video game cop head but no have you
no are you need to check it out man yeah
it's very very cool it's like nineteen
thirties shoot-'em-up okay yeah it's
really awesome
and they just kind of again I don't we
know they're getting a hitch is the
world-building sort of exercise and
that's Doomsday Clock one death watch
any any closing thoughts and just feels
like fanfiction doesn't it really yeah I
mean they've completely stolen was style
for the books even down to the ending
quote I mean they've got 11 more issues
I don't know how they all gonna pull it
off
what do you mean the other a issues is
black freighter okay no I mean I've got
to bring it in they're probably going
through in some form or they yeah we'll
get some nice cover ah like closing it
and one where you see Lex Luthor with
his hat with human dies his hand on his
shoulder and yeah Batman reading
Rorschach's Journal to UK and I suppose
the mine if he if you look on the last
one maybe yeah maybe the mine is the
Joker cause it does look quite similar
yeah it does doesn't it yeah but yeah I
mean we so we will be back every month
I'm kind of you know I'm kind of looking
forward to this it away we're gonna be
back twice a month now twice a month
didn't take this often I don't like this
podcast I don't like the listeners I
don't like you you [ __ ] racist yeah
hope this TV show doesn't come out too
much not see me family anymore
so uh you know comment get ours watching
the watch from party do you want to come
what did you think of this issue you
know like you say there's been a lot of
positive response for this but a lot of
it seems a bit clouded by nostalgia feel
actually mushy Allen was just walked
walked in me how so uh-oh
cook come here what do you think
doomsday car into a [ __ ] that's my [ __ ]
oh why you can't say that surely more
more more how do you like it hey yeah
how
that's what I said any fans would be
held you are you drunk I'm drunk I'm
your crackers what why the hell are you
reading
oh just read and watch and what the
hell's Watchmen you know that you know
that book you wrote no no I didn't I
didn't read that yeah I watched that
movie that watchman at Brad watchman do
you want you watch the watchman yeah it
was great
all right so you've heard a m-- Damon
Lindelof just had Alan War on the show
and he said he loved The Watchmen movie
so write all the clickbait articles
about that yeah there's an exclusive for
you a seal a heroine
all right well Alan will return you know
hopefully with the show didn't it you
know what you for by Alan what you feel
about the episode and our discussions
thank you as always for listening and
for sharing and for digging the show we
really appreciate it
death I guess you know goodbye man and
any any closing things you want a promo
or anything yeah well I just want to say
I watched an interview with Geoff Johns
the other day and he said thematically
that Watchmen was about perception
versus reality it's all counting down to
dr. Manhattan versus Superman which you
know it just sums it up really when Alan
were made Watchmen he wasn't counting
down to a big fight he wasn't counting
down we would be you know pay off
nowadays it's just all about the
headlines it's just all about who can we
make fight who and it's very shallow but
yeah I really enjoyed the book yeah yeah
it'll be interesting if anything else is
a companion to so go through and you
know compare and contrast and just
appreciate and it's cool that
something's coming out in real time that
we can do so so let us know but yeah as
always guys thanks for listening and
death cheers again ma'am take care good
night
[Music]